c'est la première du spectacle et un
acteur dans la fleur de l'âge tomberait
de mort sur scène mon personnage
principal est mort je n'y crois pas
ben on serait plus nous sans un bon
meurtre
police de New York le tueur que nous
cherchons et l'un d'entre vous
minuscule de rien du tout trouvé c'est
tueur et le seul moyen pour vous d'avoir
une première à ce spectacle
vous voulez faire un podcast avec moi
en pensant c'est tellement
en enquête
regardez cette distribution ce sont tous
des tueurs qui voudrait tuer ben c'est
peut-être leur attaque je suis très
nerveuse je suis pas à l'aise avec la
lecture à la table
la tempête se prépare je ne crois pas
que ce soit une nuit pourquoi pas
un clou alors remercie la gentiment
d'être venu c'est peut-être Kimber la
starlette accro à Tic-Toc qui avait un
plan Internet via un même
quoi vous dites ça comme ça je crois que
j'ai une piste
[Musique]
avec ce garçon avec Charles et Oliver de
quoi vous parlez tous les trois
principalement de meurtre et comment se
connecter en Bluetooth on parle beaucoup
de ça on tient quelque chose mais j'ai
besoin que vous atterriez la tension sur
vous ça c'est dans mes cordes c'est
trois fois rien c'est vraiment une
bontille parce que c'est comment je vais
le dire déjà je vais dire
[Musique]
votre pièce est un piège mortel rien
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai failli mourir trois
fois
[Musique]
il y a quelqu'un
ça fait des lustres que je suis coincé
là-dedans je suis de la barbe ça te
délite existe encore vous êtes parti
depuis 20 minutes
au théâtre tout est une question de
choix il y a ce que l'on choisit de
montrer et ce que l'on cache volontaire
c'est un indice
et les choix que nous faisons font toute
la différence
faire en discussion entre nana
tout va bien par ici bébé ouais ça roule
hein ouais là on bosse sur le spectacle
et ça va être du lourd avec moi ils vont
tout déchirer
moi cette fois-ci vous avez eu la
décence de laisser le cadavre en dehors
de l'immeuble vous ne manquez jamais une
occasion de vous taire